quick leave the room if you haven't seen
black panther dismissed black panther
leave your computer on just get out of
the room so did you pick up on all the
little references and nods to marvel
lore they worked in a black panther
probably not unless you did in which
case send me a link to some of your
videos cuz they sound great in any case
here's all the cool stuff we found in
the film's first big action sequence
kill monger and his crew pull off a
heist at an art gallery lifting among
other things a mask that he wears later
on in the film it's similar to a mask
he's worn in the comics including the
cover of Black Panther number 37 from
back in 2008 of course most of the main
characters who we meet in Black Panther
have comic-book counterparts from Durham
Ellijay to kill mugger to a copy but did
you realize that in Baku the leader of
the rival white gorilla tribe is based
on the comic book supervillain man ape
and he's not the only supporting
character with roots in the comics we
only seen the bi bay and a few scenes as
kill mongers girlfriend and
co-conspirator tilde but she's named
from the comic book character nightshade
in the comics she secretes a pheromone
that allows her to control certain
animals including werewolves oh man do
we have to wait for Black Panther 4 to
see that aside from just Marvel rips the
movie contains a lot of references to
pop culture from the world outside
Wakanda the movie opens with a flashback
to 1990s Oakland and rapper 2 short
plays on the soundtrack if he didn't
already know too short is from Oakland
so it's a fitting music choice another
fun musical note late in the film sure
he's disappointed that her trip to
California doesn't include a stop at
Coachella in 2017 one of the Coachella
headliners was Kendrick Lamar who
produced the Black Panthers soundtrack
huh see what I did there anyone give me
a ride to go cello 2018 this year and
maybe a ticket
I think Beyonce's playing director Ryan
Coogler is on record saying he
approached Black Panther as the Marvel
version of James Bond and it shows in
the finished film with a number of
references to the iconic double-oh-seven
franchise this movie opens with the hero
in the midst of another largely
unrelated adventure just like a Bond
film also the wakandan heroes are
eventually assisted by an American agent
Everett Ross who has his own agenda kind
of like James Bond sometimes CIA ally
Felix Leiter and
about those remote-control cars remember
when bond used one of those and tomorrow
never dies no not not you Millennials I
mean the old people we remember plus the
Black Panthers mission takes him to an
underground South Korea casino and what
could be more James bond-esque than an
undercover assignment at a casino even
sorta looks like the casino from Skyfall
and of course there's the character of
Cherie and her fantastic hyper
futuristic lab full of gadgets COFF COFF
Hugh off cough she also makes a what are
those joke but that has nothing to do
with James Bond it's just a meme but at
least we know that despite the isolation
what kind of still gets all the dankest
memes when she's showing off her fancy
sneakers Cherie also compares them to
the ones from that American movie their
father always used to watch we have it
on good authority that this references
the futuristic Nikes from Back to the
Future - no seriously
leticia right basically confirmed it
when our correspondent Jacqueline Kohli
asked her we swear we mentioned Martin
Freeman as Everett Ross but do you
remember this scene where he's
interrogating Andy Serkis as ulysses
klaw did you notice that this is a mini
hobbit reunion we've got Bilbo and
Gollum hanging out here this is a
special occasion it's almost you might
even say precious and this one's more a
cultural reference than a pop-culture
reference but you know that language
everyone speaks in Wakanda well there's
no real wakandan language in fact
they're all speaking Khoza one of the
official languages of South Africa
that's currently spoken by around 8
million people John Conti who plays
Black Panthers dad - Chaka speaks cosa
and taught some of it to chadwick
boseman when they were making civil war
and now it's officially wakandan in the
MCU of course this is an MCU movie and
the lead into the massive infinity war
team-up so there's a lot of notes and
references to the franchise's backstory
and continuity let's start at the end
that makes sense right
sure it does in a post-credits scene we
see sharee hanging out doing some
training with none other than bucket
ball cube Barnes the Winter Soldier
when we last caught up with Bucky and
Civil War he was in Wakanda
but refreezing himself unable to control
Hydra programming that was still
embedded in his head but here his mind
seems clear still no arm though get this
man an arm and this scene sure he also
refers to him as the white wolf in the
comics that's the nickname given to two
challahs adopted brother hunter
who leads the Wakanda secret police hmm
hmm okay that's all I got
bought quick sidenote you remember an
Avengers age of Ultron when Ultron
steals all the vibranium from Ulysses
claws safe to fashion his new body well
that was the vibranium that he had
stolen from Wakanda years before killing
what cobby's father in the process
Ultron later slices off claws arm in a
rage which is why he has that fancy new
makaan and prosthetic technology and
black panther we do know that in
addition to Black Panther and Bucky
Danai gurira as a Koi a Florence
kazoomba as a Oh and Leticia Wright as
Sheree will all reprise their roles for
infinity Warren later this year Plus
from that trailer it looks like we're
returning to what Conda probably because
there's an infinity stone there mixed in
with all that vibranium I bet that's a
whole lot of info and we got to get out
of here but can I just say one more
thing is it weird that Forest Whitaker
and Andy Serkis can't survive Disney
movies I mean rest in peace Zuri and
sauger era and claw and also Snoke I
don't know call your agents or invest in
some Kevlar or something because I'm
growing legitimately concerned as always
what did we miss
any Easter eggs any connections to the
MC universe let us know in the comments
[Applause]
you
[Applause]